AI cannot predict how human beings will
interact in the marketplace what sort of
in the same way governments can't well
well that but that's what I'm heading is
that that that is why central planning
failed
because no government had enough
knowledge we are now talking about the
hierar and knowledge problem they no
government ever had the kind of insight
to know whether what people wanted next
year was short skirts or short sleeved
shirts uh or long sleev shirts just
didn't know right you couldn't predict
it is not clear to me how AI could ever
predict the future um in in that kind of
way and therefore centrally plan the
economy to produce for this Marxist
Utopia as opposed to the uh Market
mechanism and the price mechanism that
we are aware of today right